The SCP Foundation’s existence might be
a frightening thing to some, but if you ask
us, it’s comforting.
Of course, the existence of the Foundation
implies the existence of all the mind-meltingly
terrifying entities they combat on a daily
basis, but doesn’t it put your mind at least
a little at ease to know somebody out there
knows what’s going on?
After all, sometimes, knowledge is the only
light we have in the darkness.
It’s humanity’s greatest strength, to
know things and to act accordingly.
From knowledge, we can understand our enemies
and the threats they pose against us.
From knowledge, we can build sturdier defences.
From knowledge, we can develop the means to
finally, effectively strike back.
And nobody among the ranks of humanity has
more knowledge than the SCP Foundation.
So what happens when the knowledge of the
SCP Foundation fails us?
What happens when a concept eludes even them?
A concept like, say, SCP-2317, an old wooden
door that hides within a truly terrible secret
- A secret known by many as the Devourer Of
Worlds, a beast every bit as powerful and
unpleasant as that name suggests.
The SCP Foundation performs a complex set
of rituals every single day to keep him contained,
and if the top brass of the Foundation is
to be believed, then these rituals are effective.
But I think we all know better than to believe
everything we’re told around here, don’t
we?
The truth is this: Beyond the wooden door
known as SCP-2317, there’s a hellish desert
world, underneath which the Devourer of Worlds
awaits.
He is kept in place, bound by ancient chains
created by a race that has long since been
lost to the history books.
And while the Foundation tells its underlings
that the rituals D-Class personnel perform
here every day helps to keep these chains
in place, this is little more than a placebo.
The rituals only exist to make the Foundation
feel like they’re doing something to bide
time, while they figure out an actual lasting
solution.
In reality, based on the Foundation’s current
knowledge, these chains could break any day
now - and sadly, there’s nothing they can
do about it.
This may seem like the worst possible truth
to learn, but we can think of one even worse
truth: That “any day now”...
Is today.
When the chain breaks, the ground begins to
rumble worldwide, like an earthquake so great
it might even split the planet in two.
No conventional scientist anywhere in the
world has any idea what’s happening, but
the SCP Foundation does.
For the first time in recorded history, the
entire O5 Council are quaking.
It’s judgment day, and their every sin is
on an express trip back to get them.
They put out a call to dispatch every single
Mobile Task Force, worldwide, to come to Site
19 and combat the new threat.
But deep down, the council members silently
worried this would be about as effective as
the sham rituals they claimed every day would
protect them.
Meanwhile, Site 19 exploded.
Most of the Foundation personnel and anomalies
stationed there perished in an instance, as
a giant clawed hand rose out of the ground,
grasping at the sunlight for the first time
in millions of years since imprisonment.
Its sheer size - hundreds of kilometers in
height - displaces and destroys the land around
it as it climbs free from the earth.
The Devourer Of Worlds is a monster of such
magnitude that it dwarfs even the Foundation’s
mightiest weapons, but their Mobile Task Forces
fight valiantly - or perhaps, foolishly - nonetheless.
The Foundation went in with its finest resources
and weaponry, from advanced cruise missiles
to classified laser projectile weapons that
conventional militaries wouldn’t be finding
for another century.
And all of it amounted to about the strength
of getting a mid-rate birthday clown’s cheap
cream pie to the face.
The thick, scaly hide of the beast somehow
rejected everything they threw at it.
Jets were scrambled, flying around the Devourer’s
gargantuan head and peppering its great eye
with bullets, followed by heat-guided rockets.
Nothing.
The monster simply swatted them out of the
air with its claws.
Down below, ground forces mobilized en masse,
from tanks to turrets, unleashing all kinds
of hell onto the Devourer of Worlds from below.
And still, what good did it do?
The monster simply kept walking, killing thousands
with every footfall.
Its magnitude was simply unfathomable.
Scranton Reality anchors were placed at its
feet, in hopes of creating some kind of trap,
but its ancient flesh defied their force.
Every Mobile Task Force from Hammer Down to
Samsara did what they could, and what they
could do ultimately amounted to a fat lot
of nothing.
The rampage of the Devourer was undeterred.
Within an hour, he would reach a population
center, and then, true hell would be unleashed
upon the human race.
But sometimes, the only thing that could destroy
something inhuman was something so much more
than human.
Over in the low risk humanoid containment
center of Site 17, SCP-343, perhaps better
known as God, was watching all the horror
unfold in his mind’s eye.
So the Devourer was finally free, and wreaking
havoc on the world that he’d put so much
effort into creating.
No, no, that simply would not do.
How could he let such a vulgar creature take
billions of years of beauty, love, kindness,
happiness, and natural majesty, and turn it
all into ash and dust?
He would not stand for it.
But God, while unimaginably powerful, is a
philosopher, not a warrior.
It would be not only beneath his celestial
position, but dangerous for all life on Earth,
if he were to unleash the power required to
destroy the Devourer himself.
The armies of God are the greatest in heaven
or earth, but he would need a champion to
lead them.
And while the operatives of the SCP Foundation
fought and died bravely for the human race,
SCP-343 blipped out of Site 17, and reappeared
in the Middle East, where his champion would
be waiting, guarding the gate to paradise.
SCP-001, in this case, known as The Gate Guardian.
A huge, glowing humanoid with wings made of
fire, and a sword hotter than the sun, capable
of cleaving its enemies apart on the atomic
level.
Typically, any being who traveled within a
kilometer of the Gate Guardian would receive
this treatment - a strike so powerful that
in the aftermath, not even dust would remain.
But when SCP-343 appeared mere feet away from
the mighty Gate Guardian, the Guardian fell
to one knee and bowed its glowing head in
holy reverence.
“Master,” the Guardian said.
“You have returned to me, at long last.
I will do thy bidding.
What must be done?”
“Uriel,” God said, gravely.
“An enemy is at the gates, one more powerful
than this world has ever known.
Battle him, while I gather the armies.
Do whatever it takes.
He must be stopped.”
The Gate Guardian, Uriel, rose to his feet,
spreading his great wings of fire.
“It shall be done, my Lord,” Uriel boomed,
and faster than any human being could possibly
perceive it, he had taken off into the sky,
leaving the gate behind him unguarded for
the first time in the memory of the human
race.
God sighed.
It was time to finally open it.
Back with the Devourer, and the Mobile Task
Force army trying in vain to slow his advance.
For the most part, the creature’s hide was
so thick, it was hard to even know if he noticed
most of the puny humans firing on it.
Some of the ones down below, driven half mad
with fear, rage, and the crushing weight of
futility, pulled out knives, swords, and bayonets
and ran at the creature’s feet, stabbing
away even as their blades were blunted and
destroyed.
Of course, the Devourer Of Worlds paid no
mind to them, it had something else in its
sights: A human city, a mere handful of steps
away.
Yes, yes, so teeming with life, such delicious
morsels.
The Devourer would live up to his terrifying
namesake and feast on them all.
Yes, yes, it would be... delicious.
As he crushed further thousands of Mobile
Task Force soldiers below him just by walking,
he could hardly wait...
Down below, things had never seemed so hopeless.
Was this how it ended?
One impotent last stand as a hungry monster
of inconceivable size bulldozed through life
and civilization and left nothing, nobody,
in its wake?
Was this how the complicated but proud story
of the human race would come to an end, down
here in the worthless, blood-soaked mud?
That’s when something changed.
The sky, once blotted out with the Devourer’s
shadow, was lit up by a brilliant, white light.
A light so dazzling, so holy and pure, that
it gave even the Devourer pause.
The human beings down below wept with joy
and numinous awe.
It was him.
It was SCP-001, the Gate Guardian, spreading
his fiery wings and drawing his solar sword.
“My Master ordered me to destroy you,”
his deafening psychic voice boomed.
“And thus, you shall be destroyed.
Prepare to meet your maker.”
The Devourer immediately let out a world-shaking
roar, so powerful that many of the humans
down below felt their brains rattling and
their ears literally beginning to bleed.
The beast reached for Uriel with its huge,
clawed hand, moving at impossible speeds for
a creature its size.
Onlookers gasped in shock.
Luckily, for as surprisingly fast as the Devourer
Of Worlds was, Uriel was faster.
Like the flash of an exploding lightbulb,
the Guardian darted out of the Devourer’s
palm and cleaved a glowing gash into the monster’s
wrist with his solar sword.
The creature growled, taken off guard.
It was the first time in millions of years,
since it was attacked and bound by those impossible
celestial armies, that it had felt pain.
What was this mysterious warrior of fire?
All the Devourer knew was that if it wanted
to turn the planet earth into an all you can
eat buffet, it would need to do away with
this glowing nuisance first.
“DIE!”
the psychic voice of the Gate Guardian commanded,
as it flew in for another strike, this time
cleaving into the beast’s torso and leaving
a long, glowing scar.
But he didn’t stop there.
The Gate Guardian had changed posture from
a defensive, territorial stance to an all-out
offensive warpath, as commanded by his all-powerful
master.
Uriel was not arrogant, he could see that
the beast he was battling was undeniably formidable.
But he had slain formidable enemies before,
and he would do so again now.
Taking advantage of the comparative slowness
and clunkiness of the Devourer - a natural
side effect of its truly immense size - Uriel
decided to stay mobile, flying around the
Devourer like an electron orbiting the nucleus
of an atom.
At any moment that he, with his warrior’s
judgment, detected an opening, a weakness,
he flew in and struck with extreme fury, leaving
another glowing scar in the monster’s thick
scales that fizzled with the impossible heat
of his sword.
Each time, the beast gave a grunt or a growl
in confused pain, as it desperately flailed
to try and grab the holy warrior.
Meanwhile, the SCP Foundation had figured
out what was happening, and was reorienting
its focus.
While the Gate Guardian fought against and
distracted the Devourer Of Worlds, all surviving
Foundation personnel, under the instruction
of the O5 Council, converged on the nearest
city to the Devourer.
They would evacuate as many as they could,
buying them more time to calculate some kind
of meaningful counteroffensive to this XK-Class
End of the World Scenario.
If this really could be humanity’s last
stand, they would go out swinging, and leave
their opponent with a black eye.
While the evacuation efforts were underway,
Uriel continued his relentless assault against
the Devourer, carving scar after scar into
the monster’s body.
He couldn’t tell if he was leaving much
lasting damage, but at the very least, he
was getting the abomination’s attention.
After striking its body countless times, though,
Uriel finally felt bold enough to go against
the creature’s obvious weak point: Its huge,
staring, cycloptic eye.
Perhaps, with a decisive strike, he could
blind the beast.
Faster than the speed of sound, Uriel orbited
the beast’s body, and reoriented himself
in front of its eye.
He could feel the nanoseconds passing as he
charged, raising his sword.
Now would be the time to end this.
But wait... what’s that?
Why is the Devourer’s eye suddenly glowing
red?
Before even Uriel had time to react, a tremendous
force of pure energy blasted forth from the
Devourer’s eye, bombarding the angelic soldier
and firing him straight into the ground below.
He didn’t even know the monster possessed
such a power, and now, the force of it was
hammering him into the earth.
The blast kept going for a few more seconds,
sapping Uriel’s strength and introducing
him to a long-forgotten pain.
When the beam was done firing, Uriel felt
as though he could barely move.
He was a sitting duck.
That’s when the Devourer began marching
towards him, every step rattling the earth.
Even as the threat loomed, Uriel couldn’t
move.
Was this the end?
“Forgive me, Master,” Uriel said.
“I have failed you...”
Then, Uriel noticed something: Several projectiles
firing towards the Devourer’s head, seemingly
out of thin air.
A volley of intercontinental ballistic missiles,
each equipped with a nuclear payload, exploded
against the creature’s head, blasting it
with a shockwave that rattled the mighty creature
on its feet.
Had human beings made such weapons?
If they could still fight, even after all
this, Uriel thought, then I must fight too.
I must fight to my last breath!
As the Devourer steadied itself, recovering
from the nuclear bombardment to the head,
Uriel rose with a terrifying warrior’s roar,
feeling his holy power return to him.
His sword ignited and he charged forward,
faster than ever before, ready to strike clear
and true...
into the Devourer’s wretched heart.
Before the beast could react, Uriel shoved
his sword into the center of its chest, causing
veins of agonizing flame to spread out over
its whole body.
At long last, he had well and truly harmed
the unharmable.
That knowledge sanctified him, even as the
Devourer Of Worlds grabbed Uriel in his fist,
and squeezed the life out of the warrior for
God for the last time.
Good, the Devourer thought, in its own way.
I can finally carry on now.
“You fought bravely, Uriel,” said a booming
voice from above the beast.
“Your sacrifice will not be in vain, that
much, I promise you.”
Confused, the Devourer turned and looked skyward,
only to see a sight that struck pure and undiluted
awe into even him: It was God and his army.
SCP-343 floated in the sky, lightning emanating
from his very being.
Around him, glowing, angelic warriors, each
as large and as powerful as Uriel, and as
numerous as the stars in the sky above.
God pointed at the Devourer.
“Now, my children,” he said.
“Take that thing apart for me.”
Want an anomaly of your own?
Check out www.scpswag.com for high-quality
SCP merch!
Now go check out “SCP-2317 - The Devourer
of Worlds / A Door to Another World” and
“SCP-001 - The Gate Guardian” for more
on today’s cosmic combatants!